[Music]
steve believed in you
he trusted you
why'd you give up that shield
i did what i thought was right
the legacy of that shield is
complicated
i am captain america
[Music]
i know all you have to do
a word of advice then stay the hell out
of my way
we've bled this country
shield or no shield
i'm not gonna let anybody tell me i
can't fight for
we don't want anyone else to get hurt
you don't want to do this
yeah we do
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
marvel just gave us a sneak
peek at the next two episodes coming for
the falcon and the winter soldier
and they are actually pretty revealing
and a lot of stuff that we thought was
going to happen in the next episode
is going to happen so let's go ahead and
break down this new trailer and talk
about what's going to happen
in the next couple of episodes in the
falcon and the winter soldier and how
it's going to end
and i do think we have figured out how
the show is going to end what the exact
final scene is and if sam becomes
captain america or not and when
exactly he gets the shield and is able
to finally use it now it does appear
like sam and bucky are going to be
confronting john walker but it doesn't
look like they may be confronting him
immediately after
the ending scene from the falcon and the
winter soldier episode 4 and if you have
not seen episodes 1-4 here is your
spoiler alert
as most of us know at the end of episode
4 john walker kind of went crazy and he
killed one of the flag smashers however
he didn't just
simply kill one of them he brutally
murdered one of them
in front of a lot of people who all
happen to be video recording on their
phones
so this is obviously not good news for
john walker considering he is supposed
to be the face
and symbol for america and the symbol of
hope like the shield is supposed to be
and in one scene it does seem like he
has to pay for what he's done like he's
being questioned about everything that
happened and he says
i am captain america this thing could be
a flashback or it could be after the
fact because we do see him
clearly confronting the flag smashers at
one point in time in this trailer
throwing the shield at carly in which
she just simply kicks it away
but since carly did kill battlestar he
is definitely going to be going after
them still and here's something that's
actually rather interesting to
note at the very end john walker is in
some sort of a warehouse by himself
there is blood still on the shield after
he killed one of the flag smashers so
this is clearly
right after that happened and this is
where sam and bucky come up to him and
he says
you don't want to do this and bucky says
yeah we do
they are clearly going to fight john
walker for the shield after he just
murdered somebody in front of a lot of
people but what's interesting is that we
see john walker
in other scenes that we haven't seen yet
in this trailer where he has the shield
and the shield is clean it has no blood
on it so
one of three things could be happening
here one is that bucky and falcon
fight john walker and john walker
actually beats them
now this isn't impossible considering
the fact that john walker has taken a
super soldier serum and according to dr
nagel it's actually a perfected serum
and if it is truly perfected then it's
most likely stronger than the one that
bucky has
as far as we know nobody has really been
able to perfect the super soldier serum
since irkskin
so yes bucky is enhanced with a type of
super soldier serum that hydra gave him
in which it's most likely not a perfect
serum but
john walker may have gotten a perfect
serum meaning he
could actually be stronger than bucky
and even if he's not stronger than bucky
right now he is definitely stronger than
falcon because falcon doesn't have any
type of serum in him now falcon can hold
the zone he's very good in hand-to-hand
combat he's done a good job against the
flag smasher
so far plus he has all of his equipment
all of his tech that's really helped him
out so far
so in theory the two of them should be
able to take on john walker
however if john walker has a perfect
serum in him much like steve rogers's
serum
and he has the shield to use in battle
then it's definitely a possibility that
he could
actually take on bucky and sam somewhat
defeat them
and run away with the shield now other
factors could come into play like the
door milaje could show up again
zemo could show up again or the flag
smashers could even show up again as
well and they could interrupt the fight
and this could lead to john walker
getting away
and that's one possibility another
possibility is that they simply defeat
john walker
and there's another shield lying around
somewhere now this one is less likely
than the first one
the only reason that john walker has
that shield is because sam decided to
give it up he didn't know they were
going to give it to a new captain
america but the fact is the only reason
john walker has that shield
is because sam gave it up but there is
always the possibility that they could
create another shield or had a different
one lying around somewhere
now if they did have another shield it
most likely wouldn't be made out of
vibranium
however wakanda did open their resources
up to essentially the world
and although it probably wouldn't be too
easy it wouldn't necessarily be
impossible for
america to get their hands on some
vibranium especially if you consider
that t'challa was working with the
avengers during the events of captain
america civil war
kind of at least but then in avengers
infinity war and avengers end game
so it wouldn't be unheard of for there
to be another shield and i think this
would make for a really cool final scene
right after john walker murdered one of
the flax masters he runs away to kind of
mourn for lamar inside of a warehouse
there bucky and sam follow him they
fight him and they get the shield away
from him
john walker goes back to the united
states and talks about what happens
answers for what he did america says
he's okay and gives him a new shield in
which we would have a scene that would
be a fight between john walker's captain
america with a shield and sam
and bucky with a shield as well i think
this would make for an insanely cool
scene
shield vs shield and this could happen
but like i said this is less likely to
happen than the first option
the third option is that they all
actually decide to work together
in which in this case they would let
john walker keep the shield at least
until they were finished with the
mission sam and bucky already had a
conversation on a plane about taking the
shield from john walker
bucky wants to take the shield but sam
doesn't
he knows the consequences of what's
going to happen if they take that shield
away from john walker
and john walker most likely knows what
will happen to them if they take the
shield from him and he'll most likely
remind them of it so even though bucky
wants to take the shield and they might
even fight for it in this scene i think
ultimately john walker is going to keep
it because falcon is going to decide
that taking it away from him is not
worth the repercussions
right now sam and bucky are free men
they've been
pardoned and they're dealing with
terrorists right now and even though
john walker has screwed up
royally he's still technically on their
side he wants to help take down the flag
smashers
so what could end up happening here is
that they simply let john walker keep
the shield
they may not exactly team up but they
will end up fighting together against
the flag smashers at some point in time
now at one point in time in this new
trailer we do see sam and it looks like
he has returned
to talk to isaiah bradley we met isaiah
bradley in episode 2.
in the comics he was the first black
captain america and in episode 2 we
learned just how poorly he was treated
by his own people
now throughout the series sam has
clearly been struggling to decide what
the shield means to him
he struggled with the decision to either
keep it or give it up he's been
struggling with
whether he should have destroyed it or
not essentially he has been struggling
with
if it's good or bad and it looks like
this conflict has taken him to isaiah
bradley to get his
opinion and advice on it and as we can
see here he says shield or no shield
i'm not going to let anybody tell me i
can't fight for it
this is another sign that he doesn't
actually get the shield from john walker
during that fight but it looks like sam
has decided that the shield
does mean a great deal to him and is
worth fighting for
and i actually don't think sam is going
to get the shield until the very end of
the final
episode i think unfortunately the scenes
that we've seen
where sam is training with the shield
and bucky is there at his family's home
are the final scenes of the series and
the scene where sam is walking away with
the shield and bucky is walking the
other way
i think that's the very last scene i
think at the very end sam finally grabs
the shield and becomes the new captain
america and bucky goes his own way
i do think sam is going to end up using
the shield at some point in time during
the final episode when john walker is
there fighting the flag smashers as well
i think the shield will go between the
two of them but i don't think the shield
actually becomes his until the ending of
the final episode
and i think that'll leave us with a sort
of cliffhanger sam becoming the new
captain america
and bucky going his own way but we only
have about a week and a half until we
figure it all out so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos in the meantime
and let me know your final predictions
for the series in the comments down
below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter or tick tock
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof